صندلي موروث شعبي افغاني قديم للتدفئه هي
طاوله من خشب يسمى الارشا توضع وسط غرفه
في البيت مع كميه من الجمر وبقايا براده
الخشب يغطيها الرماد
ويغطى ببطانيه سميكه
ليستمر انبعاث الحراره لاكثر من اثنتي
عشره ساعه
لا يمكنك ان تحافظ على درجه حراره الغرفه
من دون صندلي فالجو بارد جدا هنا تستطيع
التحكم في درجه حراره الغرفه بشكل افضل
سعرها رخيص مقارنه بالكهرباء وادوات
التدفئه الاخرى
[موسيقى]
حلقه عائليه يتوارثها الاباء عن الاجداد
منذ نحو 200 عام يتداول الناس قصصهم في
اجواء يبث فيها صندلي دفئا على مدى اشهر
الشتاء البارده اطول ليله في الشتاء
الافغاني تسمى وهي اكثر ليله تكون الحاجه
فيها ماسه لاستخدام صندل حيث يتسامر افراد
الاسره بينما يتوغل الليل ومن بعض ما يقال
في مقام صندل تنذرا الشعور بان راسك في
سيبيريا وجسمك في جلال اباد نسبه لدفع
المكان عندما تصل الحراره الى 25 مئويه
تحت الصفر يستعين الافغاني بصندل فهي
الطريقه المثلى للتدفئه في مختلف ارجاء
افغانستان نظرا لضعف التيار الكهربائي
والوضع المالي الصعب
سيدنا نافذ النجار الوحيد الذي يصنع صندلي
في جبل سراج بولايه بارون
يستغرق الانجاز ساعه او اكثر حسب حجمها
مهنه تكاد تنقرض اذ تراجع الطلب عليها لكن
يبقى اغلب زبائنها من الفقراء
ومتوسطي الدخل
منذ 18 عاما في سابق كان الوضع الاقتصادي
جيدا لكنه الان تراجع بسبب العوز والفقر
هذه وسيله فعاله للتدفئه لكنها تحتاج الى
اموال وليست متوفره للجميع
ولصندل تاريخ في المنطقه فالاسم نفسه في
ايران ودول من اسيا الوسطى هي ثقافه
مشتركه
ومنقذ مهم من برد الشتاء كلما اتجهت شمالا
ناصر شديد الجزيره من جبل سراج بولايه
باروان شماليه افغانستان